and it is the day before Thanksgiving
when millions of us leave home for the
holiday expecting the worst people are
on the move right now in Dallas Atlanta
and the Northeast some of them in New
York are already stuck in traffic that's
only gonna get worse triple-a predicts
more than 54 million Americans will
travel this week 4.3 million of us are
expected to fly for Thanksgiving so get
ready be patient that's an increase of
more than five percent from last year
Kris Van Cleave is at Chicago's O'Hare
International to see how one of
America's busiest airports is handling
its toughest week of the year hey Chris
yesterday at this time we saw you
heading to the airport I'm glad you made
it
good to see you we made it good morning
O'Hare is one of the nation's busiest
airports they're expecting more than 2
million fliers to pass through here
during the Thanksgiving holiday weekend
that means a whole lot of flights like
this one about to head to San Francisco
the people are on board I can see them
in the windows when you're down here on
the tarmac everything is about beating
the clock getting everybody on board
getting those bags loaded and getting
these planes off the gate before that
countdown clock hits zero I'm really
excited
for Thanksgiving because I kind of like
truth Patrick and the rest of the McCain
clan are flying from Chicago to Denver
for Thanksgiving at grandpa's we wanted
to avoid the craziness of tomorrow
traveling with children is a challenge
anything we can do to minimize the
disruptions is what we want to do but to
get them and the rest of the 2.2 million
who will fly United over the next few
days to their destinations on time takes
a small army under Honor I always run
from gate to gate answering calls and
radio people calling me Milo Bacall is a
flight fixer of sorts the customer
service supervisor races through O'Hare
taking care of everything from computer
issues to getting the right people on
board I remember one time few years ago
there was actually four thing around
Thanksgiving I walked 12 miles during my
shift Sunday United will operate a
record 679 flights out of Chicago enough
to fly 71 thousand people home the
flights will be monitored here in their
Airport Operations Center is the
Thanksgiving holiday kind of your Super
Bowl it is it's one of the busiest times
a year and it's really an opportunity
for us to connect people unite the world
getting the 50,000 or so bags a day
transferred and loaded will be a family
affair this Thanksgiving
Karen Pereira and her sons Chris and
Jeff will be working the ramp together
I remember saying when I was with my
mother you're not the boss of me and I
feel like this actually worked out that
literally she gets to be the boss at
home at work
and we're all about behind-the-scenes
access here at O'Hare I want to show you
some cool time-lapse video this is over
in the American Airlines terminal where
crews there have been literally decking
the halls overnight to get these
handmade Christmas decorations holiday
decorations up and in place ahead of the
holiday rush back out here on the tarmac
it is about time for this flight to head
to San Francisco Sunday is going to be
the busiest day could be the busiest
travel day of the year the TSA is
preparing for as many as 3 million or
more people to pass through checkpoints
that would be a record and this is an
on-time departure John with perhaps the
best time tag of a piece as the plane
goes out from behind him that's amazing
press master of the tarmac thank you
very nice